[Music]
each detail of the 5s is meticulously
designed engineered and crafted in a way
that no iPhone has been before no two
fingerprints are alike so we thought
with 5s why not use them as passwords
and the 5s is the first iPhone to be
offered in the color gold to achieve
this aesthetic we went outside of our
poor team of designers yeah gold is best
you think of the best stuff jet ski nice
watch sports car
shrimp he's not regular iPhone is gone I
just want to make it clear I only worked
on the gray and silver ones okay
displays base three seven cheapest
finished cheap camera space regardless
of the exterior colors all the phones
are equally as powerful on the inside
this base
[Music]
Siri is not such an uptight [ __ ] on
this one
cool feel real good we didn't really
talk to the Gold team that much as we
were in Cupertino and their offices were
based in Miami Beach you know you know
you're on the deck of a boat and there's
a hot lady on this on a hot lady on that
darn champagne cocktail tense beats
doing good
EJ says hey Rafi only the hottest tracks
for you and you're like buddy you're the
best
Goldie's best best best
[Applause]